[Music]
foreign
[Music]
unusual thing is that this skull
actually had part of the body attached
to it as well so usually what we find is
that when we're digging these things out
of the ground is that we'll find bits of
the body and no head and very very
rarely we'll find just ahead but
unfortunately with no body attached so
the fact that this guy had both allows
us to close that Gap while they have
this overlap between the body and the
head that will unravel a lot of the
species to verses how many species of
these long necked pieces also swimming
around here in this Outback Ocean 100
million years ago so when I the station
owner of this property texted me a
picture of this skull
that she had found just from digging a
little bit into the surface it was just
incredible because all we've seen so far
we've got one skull in the collection at
the Museum it's not a very nice specimen
it's quite squashed and it's got no body
attached to it so the fact that we had
it suddenly had a beautifully preserved
three-dimensional skull with the body it
means that we're going to do so much
more we still there's still so much we
don't know about these animals that were
swimming in this ancient inline sea 100
million years ago
including well how many species of these
long-necked policy sauce for instance
were there so it seems something as
simple as that just how many species
there were we don't really know exactly
so this animal here that has a head with
a body attached to it allows us to
unravel some of that species diversity
so we'll get a much better understanding
of how do these early members of this
group called The lasmosaurs evolve in
the early Cretaceous Cretaceous Period
and also Harmony species were there
around at the time